welcome to this video playing don't go
ghleanna not don't call a owner Cogliano
yeah maybe someone can translate this to
me what this actually means got Swiss
flag and we have sort of yeah English
Defence maybe I can play this transpose
to a regular twins Indian why it didn't
happen f6 is a playable move it looks a
bit strange but you can do that has been
played by teammate of mine okay write a
five or pick up the bishop but yeah it's
um it's just just a position nothing I'm
great for for for me or for him we
should put III will be maybe it will
provoke him to do anything but should be
32 maybe this capture he's not taking on
c3 maybe i can i can do a play move like
that to actually avoid the somewhat
wrecked pawn structure
hmm interesting yeah well this is this
is really a question now I can should I
play just castles on I could also try to
play it a bit a bit more ambitiously
with HOH I come I come on I don't think
castles is really a big meat he can take
on on c3 for example and then just stay
put in this position okay so let's push
this let's see now aged 6 mm rh6 a will
probably play g6 which does not look
exactly great for him but maybe it's
better than it looks
very weird okay but this is the the only
real only real consistent follow-up and
one now g6 must do that then I thought
bishop age for that was my idea wow
really he lost me to take under this
what's a very good structure it's also
night in five okay well I start with
that it's it's probably okay anyway and
now Queen tweenage five is very
attractive if I go night if I for
example and yeah yeah this should be
really good for y200 Queen age five it
takes Queen age seven King f6 I take on
you five and wind yeah okay so this is a
good move how does he protect h7 now
yeah so h4 was better at least in this
game here instead of castling not sure
about the objective merit but it looked
very very dangerous if it takes now here
only five I just play Queen age seven
king of six de five check 95 bishop h4
checkmate so on this is the
justification resign yes I'm just I'm
just meeting probably I'm h7s not
defendable yeah Brooke f6 was the move
that the comb suggests plus heaven
probably will find a mate soon later it
was a bit strange and he must play g6
just similarly which is not looking like
great but it's what you need to do
I thought about this reply Knight f6 f7
and then Bishop f6 this was my IDM
putting the bishop right into the heart
of blacks camp I can even fianchetto the
bishop when Bishop g7 looks looks really
weird yeah but it's not like I'm winning
here it's just just annoying to have
this piece here on g7 for black computer
I'm actually prefers Bishop f5 but ok
now it searches to age form so this is
probably somewhat better provide but
nothing nothing to do great business now
is that probably I probably just as it
is pure destruction I mean best defense
according to the machine is something
like that yeah it's it simply it's
simply just a good position King f1 the
computer movement yeah that's also
looking hard strong now intends to to
use this night some somewhere somewhere
even not be five might be an idea and
that protects g2 yeah why does much
better him but it's not it's not an
immediate winter like in the game it
turned out to be okay thanks for
watching